[Music]
why did they put a little rat tail I
think I complained about that shot last
time we did this piece and so they just
had this the you know I've had some kind
of neck surgery yeah I was bright I just
they just said that testing showed that
really makes you look cool yeah yeah
cool anyway I was watching TV the other
day and I was checking out the golf
champion okay
watching the Golf Channel yeah didn't
quite know it was going on so I hit the
info button and it said when all the
excitement of the fishing channel gets
to be too much watching the Bachelorette
yeah then I hit this button and it said
little tip don't get too attached to the
black guy
happens that is just a fact ladies and
gentlemen don't take that out
don't take that out on us yeah all right
Errol I was watching a show called arrow
yeah one of those superhero shows yeah
then I hit the button and it said
tonight arrow meets his toughest
opponent guys standing pretty far away
[Applause]
for mistresses I was watching the show
mistresses hmm yeah and then I was hit
the info button and it said finally the
world gets to see an hour-long yogurt
commercial Grey's Anatomy Andy I was
watching Grey's Anatomy sure Hospital
drama sure curious how will be described
if I hit the button so I hit the button
it said this show is a medical marvel it
just won't die
[Applause]
yes we're still there the Bachelorette I
was watching The Bachelorette again
again yeah yeah and I hit the end button
this time and it said some of the
nation's best Chad's convene at this
annual Chad summit right Chad I was
watching Dateline NBC yeah me wanted to
check out
honey hit the info button and it said
the husband did it
Oh 99% of the time eyes watching The
Today Show with Kathie Lee and Hoda yeah
Kathie Lee and Hoda today's show and
then I hit the button and it said
combined blood alcohol content equals
five point four eight yeah yeah and
finally I was watching The Bachelorette
one last time yep and I thought how
they're gonna scrap it this time so I
hit the button and it said dumb people
you
[Music]
you